make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing our character
explanation series what I want to do
here is I want to talk about the
character of Vulcan about Gabriel
summers I want to do a an explanation on
him and the reason why is because with
with house and powers of X going on one
of the things that you guys are aware of
is that Gabriel summers is currently
back in Marvel Comics as part of the
x-men lineup the issue at this that the
last time we saw him he was effectively
a villain right and so for him to
suddenly be thrown back in and then to
essentially be a good guy it really sort
of rings a few bells here and there but
Gabriel Summers Vulcan first appeared
back in x-men deadly Genesis number one
and 2006 and he was created by Ed
Brubaker now the idea of x-men deadly
gymnast is like kind of getting into
this I want to have this sort of
discussion about the x-men right and
we've kind of talked about this before
so for those you guys who have followed
my x-men videos very closely bear with
me for a minute while we talk about this
the publication history of the x-men and
Marvel was always pretty straightforward
right it was always relatively
straightforward at least until you got
until likely the early to mid-2000s and
then you started getting him to name
changes right like x-men legacy and all
I kind of good stuff it got kind of
crazy but the idea was that back in the
early days you had scanned me and Jack
Kirby's x-men and this lineup was pretty
basic why you had Jean Grey you had
Cyclops you had an Iceman you had angel
and you had beast and that was basically
it
that's really all yeah that original
lineup and the stories that were told
were not resoundingly popular and so
Marvel basically got rid of them in 1975
when they released giant size extra
number one I wouldn't really say they
got rid of them so much as they added to
them the landscape of the country had
changed in a lot of ways so people were
really clamoring for more diversity and
their characters and so what you got was
this essential multicultural x-men team
the result of that is that the way the
set of events originally played out is
you basically had the original x-men who
were captured by the living island of
kokoa and they were rescued by a new EX
new x-men team that was created by
Charles Xavier basically assisting a
Wolverine
storm and Colossus and Nightcrawler and
pretty much all the characters that
you're the most familiar with these days
following that both the original team
and the new team merged together and
then went forward throughout the
entirety of Chris Claremont run with
certain members being kicked out mainly
the original team more or less being
kicked out Cyclops left the team after
the death of Jean Grey at the end of the
Phoenix of the Dark Phoenix saga
Iceman and Angel ended up joining the
the defenders of Los Angeles beast
joined the Avengers themselves so they
were all kind of being ushered out more
or less all you really had was
rostro giant-size x-men being published
says the uncanny x-men lineup this ran
for quite some time and the reason why
this matters is because x-men deadly
Genesis while it shares the namesake of
giant-size x-men number one this was
basically a giant retcon like
retroactive continuity insofar as it was
designed to introduce information that
didn't exist before but the other reason
for its creation was to totally revamp
the leadership of the x-men and hand it
over to Cyclops and the reason why was
because as we talked about before
following the comment busts a lot of the
the financial struggles at Marvel is
going through a joke asada taking over
as editor-in-chief the issue is that the
x-men specifically had almost kind of
gotten out of control insofar as you had
all kinds of name changes and he had all
these crazy things going on and he had
this huge explosion of the mutant
population and he had carriers who were
dying all the time and it was getting
kind of kind of bonkers and so good
sought his response was basically like
convince the x-men number down right
like wipe out all the ones that we don't
really need and only keep the essentials
and so that's why you got House of M
where 98% of the mutant population
launched their powers but the idea here
was to also move the x-men away from the
leadership of Charles Xavier who had
essentially been the head of the team
been like the the leader of the team
pretty much since its inception as a
result of that Quezada and really a
handful of others said let's let's get
Xavier out and let's have somebody else
take over hence the reason why we got X
been deadly Genesis and what this did is
it introduced the idea that where we
previously believed that the original
x-men were rescued by the giant sized
x-men number one team the what Xavier
had done is he had actually secretly
created another team that we didn't know
existed and this team come was composed
of like Vulcan and Darwin and so on so
forth and ultimately they were all
destroyed by Kirk over the exception of
Vulcan and Darwin and Darwin because he
had the the mutant ability to adapt to
any situation had basically bonded
himself to Vulcan and then in turn
Vulcan it kind of lived on but the way
that this played out was was that when
this whole thing went down with this
whole situation kind of popped up Vulcan
just sort of appeared seemingly out of
nowhere and what we ended up learning
was that his arrival his return more or
less basically came by way of the fact
that so many meetings had lost their
powers this kind of psychic shockwave
had woken him up and he had basically
been out and spaced the entire time
within the island of kokoa which in the
original giant-size x-men comics had
been shot into space by Jean Grey and so
when he came back here he didn't really
have any recollection of who he was or
what his memories were or anything along
those lines and and Brubaker played this
pretty incredible actually over the
course of the x-men deadly genesis
comics what you end up learning
that in the old school origin of cyclops
the scenario played out whereby cyclops
and his family were essentially in a
plane they were you know they were drawn
on a family retreat or something along
those lines and their plane was suddenly
set upon by essentially this she are are
this kind of spacefaring and you know
alien empire and the result was that
cyclops inhabit were pushed out of the
plane and given parachutes and then it
was believed that his father corsair and
his mother had died now during chris
claremont run it was revealed that
corsair was actually alive but the
result was that we ended up learning
from x-men deadly genesis is that the
mother of cyclops was pregnant with a
third son and so ultimately this son was
essentially taken from her and then when
corsair tried to make it at him to
escape the mother was killed as it was a
way to basically explain why it is that
the mother of cyclops in them had never
been around despite the fact that
corsair wasn't following this Vulcans
origin basically played out in such a
way to where he was artificially aged up
and then he was sent to earth and the
idea behind this was that at the time
earth was really being monitored by a
guy named davon Shikari who also
operated under the mantle of erik the
red he was essentially an agent of
infrared akin who was the guy that was
leading the Shiar empire at the time and
vulcan was sent to earth in order to be
his servant more or less you know in
order to carry out the various schemes
and so on that that era thread wanted to
implement the issue with his end really
the way this played out really kind of
came to a head in a couple different
ways the first way was that when vulcan
arrived on the scene he was discovered
by mora McDonough who was a friend of
Charles Xavier in a meeting geneticist
and more macabre didn't really know what
to make of the powers of Vulcan I so the
result was that she brought him under
her wing and studied his abilities the
second thing about this is this all kind
of coincided with the capture of the
original x-men team by the living island
of cacoa and so as a result of that
Xavier he basically traveled to more
McTaggart learning that she had various
mutants under her under her purview
recruited them to his cause and then
sent them there now the idea behind more
McAlary to the time where she disagreed
with the idea right she didn't like that
because she felt like they weren't
trained well enough that Charles Xavier
was sending them on a suicide mission
and where Xavier used his his abilities
to essentially speed up their training
by having them gauge engage in battles
that were all fought on kind of a
psychic plane believing that they were
that it would really train them up to
the level they needed to be in order to
rescue the original x-men ultimately it
didn't work and so this basically led
him to what we talked about before
whereby all the secret x-men as we'll
call them were killed off by Kirk OA
except for Darwin and Vulcan and so
without having been the case this
kind of came together in coalesce with
the launcher giant-size x-men this goes
into the desire to replace Charles
Xavier because Charles Xavier had been
old hat because he was he was kind of
looked at it as okay this guy's been
leaving the team forever but like we
want to shift things up we want to
change things the idea was to begin the
process of moving in the direction of
Cyclops taking over the x-men but the
problem is you couldn't just have it
happen one day right because the way the
Cyclops character had been written over
the years is he was like the believer he
was the guy who always believed in what
Xavier was was espousing the idea of a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
Utahns and he would lay his life on the
line to ensure that dream came to came
to fruition and so when when the events
of House of M transpired and
ninety-eight percent of the mutant
population lost their powers Xavier was
nowhere to be found and Cyclops and Emma
Frost were the ones who took over the
x-men team had there not been a reason
for Cyclops to doubt the leadership of
Xavier then as soon Xavier came back
Cyclops would have handed the mantle
right back over and it would have been
right back to business as usual and so
the purpose behind this story was to
essentially seed doubt it was to
basically bring to light this revelation
that Charles Xavier had a secret x-men
team one of which he knew was this was
the brother of Cyclops and never told
him not only that seemingly set him on a
suicide mission and so once x-men deadly
Genesis came to an inn and Vulcan was
essentially defeated which by the way
you were welcome to check that video out
here on my channel I've got us you can
watch the whole thing but once that
story came to an end to end Volken was
essentially defeated and basically took
off in his space when he learned that
the true killer of his mother was
basically emperor dak in this had two
big ramifications the first and the part
that we're gonna follow here is we're
going through the easy actuation of
Vulcan is that he took off into space to
go after the Shiar
the second is that as far as the main
line x-men comics went this led Cyclops
to believe that really Xavier was
essentially a duplicitous man rather he
was a dubious man because he had kept so
many secrets and so that set the stage
for Cyclops to basically refused to
allow leadership of the x-men for Xavier
a lot of the other x-men to really
follow suit behind Cyclops and for him
to take over that leadership role going
forward which really led all the way up
to the death of Xavier during the events
of Avengers vs. x-men but for Vulcan
himself following the events of x-men
deadly Genesis this went into really a
pretty significant run for his character
which was called the rise and fall of
the Shiar Empire now for the first half
of the story and because of the fact
that Marvel was sort of gambling on the
idea that a lot of people were going to
be getting
into the x-men following the events of
house of M and we're most likely
unfamiliar with the stories of Chris
Claremont really Marvel kind of treated
the the rise and fall of the Shiar
Empire it's kind of a introduction into
what the Shiar Empire were in so far as
they were largely an avian race and so
far as they looked like birds or at
least had bird-like features feathers
different things like that as well as
the structure of leadership in the sense
that were de kin had been leader during
the time when Vulcans mother was
kidnapped in the very very early days of
the x-men
they can't had long since been defeated
and was basically in a comatose state
and so as a result of this the entire
empire was being ruled over by lilandra
who had really been the one to take over
following the events of the original
Phoenix and Dark Phoenix saga as the
initial defeat of de Ken this basically
led to kind of informational kind of
structure which made sense because the
entire story arc is around 12 issues
long once you get into the second half
that's when Vulcan started to make his
move Vulcan actually ended up falling in
love or at least you know temporarily in
somewhat of a romantic relationship with
a character named death bird who is
basically the sister of lilandra who had
always been plotting to overthrow a
laundry anyway but during that entire
set of events because the x-men were
kind of in a position where exam yers
powers hadn't yet returned or anything
like that it was kind of this huge
sequence of events that really shifted
the landscape in a lot of different ways
and so Xavier was essentially exposed to
the m'kraan crystal by Vulcan which
basically restored his powers dickin was
killed and then Vulcan took over the
Empire and so as a result of that Vulcan
was now be de facto leader of the Shiar
going forward which worked because for
the most part I mean aside from super
hardcore fans who have been reading
since the era of Chris Claremont most
people were new right most people who
had been reading the x-men up to that
point it picked up in the mid to late
90s and really weren't too satisfied
with what they were seeing and so what
they were getting at this point was
really kind of a huge explosion you know
with regards to what they saw before
what this did is it basically tied into
a lot of the offense it really began to
kind of shift away from what was going
on explicitly with the x-men and
actually began to shift into everything
that was going on with Dan Abnett now to
talk about this for a second Marvel's
cosmic landscape as it exists now did
not use to be that way really before
2006 Marvel's cosmic landscape while it
did exist was really more of a sequence
of stories involving particular
characters as opposed to like one great
big cohesive opera he looked at stories
like Infinity Gauntlet infinity war so
on and so forth and those are a big
crossover events and even then he looked
at it runs of like Adam warlock by jim
Starlin he looked at like these various
things that took place and it was lousy
around individual characters Wendell
Vaughn quasar the original Captain
Marvel of the Creed but it wasn't like
this massive set of events that you
looked at and was like this all takes
place in space that all changed in 2006
with a story called annihilation an
annihilation was basically designed to
kind of kind of consolidate all these
spacefaring characters and then bring
them all into a single event that would
basically catapult and go into a
sequence of massive events all of which
took place in space and so what this did
is it went to a to a sequence of stories
you basically had war of kings who had a
realm of kings and run things along
those lines
but all this really kicked off with
essentially a giant civil war that took
place inside the Shiar Empire itself now
by this point the character of all could
have been taken over by Christopher Yost
right he and Craig Tyler basically made
their bones in the x-men evolution with
the introduction of x-23 and really
struck a chord is the potential that
they could they could produce as far as
comics went in Marvel proper and so as
results that Marvel basically started
producing this comic called x-men
Emperor Vulcan which basically focused
explicitly on what it was that they
Gabriel Sommers was doing between the
time that he took off and and and I
guess really here are the events of a
rise and fall the Shiar empire going
into basically war of kings and during
this time the way he was written was was
really more of a character in so far
that he was rejected by the Shiar who
were very much a society that didn't
want anybody outside the Shiar itself to
rule them and so what ended up happening
as part of the story is there was a
group that was introduced
they were basically called the m'kraan
now at the time the sword was made they
were called the the sky I think is what
it was but basically the gist behind
this is that a Marvel Comics you have
what's called the m'kraan crystal and
we've clarified that before insofar as
the crystal is basically like this giant
hallway of doors and that each door
would lead to a different universe right
and if you were to crack the m'kraan
crystal or crack one of the doors so to
speak that would basically lead to the
collapse of the multiverse right so it
was an insanely powerful artifact the
idea was that it originally belonged to
a race called the m'kraan which were
ultimately more or less defeated by the
Shiar who in turn took the concept of
the m'kraan crystal
and then basically repurposed it said it
was a gift given to them by their by
their God shower in ki3
and then went forward from there and so
because of the fact that the the m'kraan
race itself view their birthright as
having been stolen by the Shiar and then
in turn repurposed as their own they in
turn swore to basically destroy the
Shiar and so what this did is it offered
the perfect opening for Vulcan in so far
that he basically led the assault
against the m'kraan race ultimately
ended up defeating
and then earning not really the right of
leadership so much as greater approval
in the eyes of the Shiar empire and that
basically sort of turned the tide a
little further in its favor in terms of
winning those individuals over who were
still loyal to lilandra
but the circumstance surrounding this
was that following that what you ended
up going into was the war of Kings now
something that I do want to point out
here is that for a lot of the events
that were going on with regards to the X
in themselves X been divided we stand
amasai complex and things like that that
was all basically Ed Brubaker along with
a handful of others who were focusing on
those stories and and for the most part
spoken didn't really have any any goings
on with that instead there were some
stories like x-men king breaker that
basically focus on the idea of Vulcan
having essentially won over the Shiar
Empire and then in turn imprisoning
lilandra in the beginning this sort of
conquest of expansion which is to say
expanding the Shiar Empire out belong I
guess outside of its existing borders
but what this did is it really coincided
with the expansion of the of the
Inhumans themselves and the reason why
was because the Inhumans in Marvel
Comics had launched since existed as
this essential experiment by the by the
Kree right the way just played out
during I want to say it was Jonathan
Hickman's run on the Fantastic Four's
when this was explained is that in the
early days of Earth that of course you
had the Celestials who showed up who
modified the genes of early man and so
on and so forth created the the deviants
and the Eternals then baseline humans
who would eventually go on to become
mutants around that same time the Kree
were at war with the scrolls and because
of the fact that earth is in a strategic
location between these two races in so
far that whatever race conquers Earth
will gain a foothold of over the other
in this you know kree-skrull war that's
been going on for millennia offer for
countless eons this basically led to the
Creed viewing earth and then taking some
of those individuals and bringing them
into the inhuman project now the inhuman
project was actually a universal wide
project the idea behind this though for
the Cree was to essentially create a
circumstance whereby they could
genetically modify individuals so that
when they were exposed to the equivalent
of Earth's Terrigen mist that their true
form would manifest and then as agents
of the Cree it would go forward in
whatever race they matched and then in
turn like infiltrated ultimately because
of the fact that there was so much
uncertainty and because the supreme
intelligence who was the leader of the
Cree believed the races destruction
would come into hands of one of their
inhuman experiments
it essentially ordered the disbanding
and the destruction of all the
experiments at that point the Inhumans
essentially survived the whole
attempted a purge and then just resided
on earth for eons the problem is that in
a lot of ways and not even to really rag
on the Inhumans but in a lot of ways
they were always kind of viewed as a
poor man's x-men and Marvel and so
nothing really ever seemed to come of
them and indeed up until this point the
only really good Inhumans run you saw
was vol 2 by Paul geing is in jail II in
order to kind of shake things up the
Inhumans essentially ended up leaving
earth and then traveling to the Kree
Empire at that point in time the Kree
was being led by Ronon the accuser who
was challenged by by Black Bolt and
whoever won would can't would would
basically take over leadership if Ronon
won he would continue in his role if
Black Bolt won he would take over
leadership the result is that Black Bolt
ended up winning and so ultimately the
Kree Empire fell under the control of
the Inhumans but because it was a newly
conquered Empire essentially and in a
relatively weakened state Vulcan was
written during the war of kings - making
his move against the creek which led to
a massive battle against the against the
Kree themselves as well as the Shiar
Empire led by Vulcan now worth Keys
itself was a pretty significant event it
was a pretty massive conflict when you
consider the grand scope of everything
that was involved and the reason why I
say that was that at the time under Dan
Abnett like a lot of events had taken
place right like Vulcan was only one
part of it and 2006 you ended up getting
annihilation the following year you
ended up getting anihilation conquest
there were a lot of things that were
happening with war of kings because of
the fact that this was designed to be
just kind of another event going on in
an ongoing series of events Vulcan while
he was leader of the Shiar wasn't really
seen as like a long-term individual in
Marvel Comics in reality it sort of made
sense right not so far in that the
cosmic scope is where you went to you
when you wanted to cancel characters but
insofar that putting him there really
offered Marvel the position of testing
the waters and seeing how fans responded
as far as his character went the reality
of Vulcan is that while his powers were
really intriguing which is to say the
ability to manipulate any kind of energy
while he was omega-level and that was
cool the reality of this was that
Marvel's cosmic scope was in a lot of
ways dwarfing the popularity of what was
going on on earth and so really in a lot
of ways walking just kind of fell to the
wayside and this all came to a head at
the end of the ward King's event when
Vulcan and black bone officially went to
war right it was technically Vulcan who
made the first strike when he
interrupted the marriage between Ronon
the accuser and crystal of the Inhumans
which would unite the Kree and end the
inhuman tribes when that when that whole
attack was launched by Vulcan it
basically set in motion the war that was
initiated between the two of them but
with with blackballed and and really
with this conflict you know kind of
ripping a hole in space basically this
essentially saw the the cool unquote
defeat of Vulcan where he was
essentially that's kind of like shuffled
out which is to say he was written out
in the sense that he was sucked into a
void never really the to be seen or
heard from again at least as far as we
were aware what this did is it just kind
of allowed Dan Abbott to continue on now
removing Volker from the equation
throwing the Shiar in a disarray as far
as leadership went and that is kind of
going forward from there the reality is
it led to gladiator taking over the
Shiar becoming the new Magister and then
he was the one kind of running the show
but it also went into like the Thanos
imperative storyline I work out of that
rift that was created during war of
Kings came the cancerverse but as one of
the things understand is that following
the events of war of kings and going
into house of X which is to say what's
going on right now with Jonathan Hickman
welcome was gone but he hadn't he hadn't
been around since then right so really
for like the last ten years
what could have been missing in action
from Marvel Comics and it's one of the
things that people tend to forget where
they think about the character of Vulcan
in and Marvel and they believe that he's
always kind of been there right in the
other that that you know really when he
was only around for about three or four
years did they think that he'd been
around for like ten fifteen years
running all the way up until right now
and that was never really the case he
was a character that appeared for a very
brief amount of time he has some really
really cool stories and he had some huge
moments but he was by no means one of
the great big huge long-lasting
characters in marble having said that
but the fact that he's here during the
events of house and powers of X
indicates there's gonna be a big world
of play right bring it here to like that
back onto the board it's no small thing
you're talking about a guy who could
manipulate any form of energy out there
and so when you're talking about a
character like that with him showing up
alongside the x-men they could basically
curtail virtually any threat that exists
out there because Walken himself his
face off forgets are pretty heavy
hitters but in terms of what we'll see
where this character is Jonathan Hickman
right so it's anybody's guess the the
beauty but the struggle of Jonathan
Hickman writing is that where you think
he's gonna go right ah you may gonna be
like well I mean he might go right but
most likely he'll go left and he doesn't
do either he goes straight you know it
was kind of like alright I just want to
sort of see how this goes so there's no
real guessing with that but the idea
here is that Vulcan is currently back we
don't know what role he plays there
really seems to be no indication at
least in terms of his mannerisms or any
references that he was ever like in
control to see our empire that he ever
tried to like destroy Cyclops or any of
those guys or anything along those lines
everything's
pathetic as it was kind of interesting
to see how that's gonna be reconciled
with his past if it's reconciled at all
it may just be that he's there and
Hickman never does anything with him but
regards to the circumstance it is cool
to see him back that's more or less
Vulcan explained again
he was only around for about three or
four years not a great big huge amount
of history there but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explained make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]